citizens of the reject Nation welcome to
the first Bostonian team up on the
reject Nation I'm here with the ever
lovely ever effervescent ever World
girly Roxy's try how are you doing do
you think that's true we're the first
two-time Boston people on the show
two-time returning Champions some people
are gonna love this who else would it be
uh maybe Jason Tatum he's in here all
the time uh Mark Wahlberg Ben Affleck
pops by should we go back and forth with
them
Mark Wahlberg I just said that I came in
with Mark Wahlberg I was distracted to
that picture Matt Damon and so it threw
me because that's why I went Ben Affleck
sometimes I see Matt when you say Mark
um some other woman I don't know why
when I think of Boston I only come up
with man John Krasinski B.J Novak yeah
there's a lot of dudes yeah where are
the women
speaking of women this movie might have
some but we don't know that because we
haven't seen it this is our first watch
of the thing a movie I got a lot of crap
about having not seen yeah me too for a
really long time people have said that
this is the best body horror movie and
I've never seen it and I'm excited to be
able to shut people down now we're gonna
watch the thing please do like subscribe
hit that notification Bell leave a
comment below of which is your favorite
Bostonian US hunt Roxy down on world
girls they got a lot of cool stuff I
like that new tracksuit please do check
this out as well over on patreon if you
want to watch it front to back sink to
sync start to finish with us just
watching the whole time that's how you
get it here on YouTube you can see you
know pieces of our experience if you
want the entire Journey including our
resting watching faces like this
that's where you go over the patreon to
hunt us down there and let's watch the
thing
[Music]
good
I actually don't know much John
Carpenter work which is crazy because I
know that I do this for a living and
he's like the God of this but it was
like just before our time like are you
saying we're young yeah
it's about aliens
I know so
I'm So Smooth we put on Star Wars we did
accidentally John Carpenter Star Wars
here's the thing
here's the thing okay UFO stuff what
nope not a UFOs laughing because I was
like I think that's a helicopter
actually
you know standard issue helicopter
that dog gets hurt I swear to good
where's the dog coming from
don't you do it
don't you do it do we never find out the
dog's name oh my God
don't love this is it is it an alien
Peta PETA
okay he's either a very bad shot or that
dog is bulletproof is he trying to tag
him that's a gun right it sounds like
bullets yeah those don't sound fun
this is a beautiful quality for like an
80s movie which looks great he's
beautiful quality I mean he's beautiful
that helps that I mean that is the shot
I saw and went beautiful
I don't understand how the agility of a
dog is taking down a helicopter and a
theoretical sharpshooter
I think the dog's the alien he's the
thing
[Music]
on the dog are they gonna guess the dog
what is this classic movie don't you
guess that dog oh my God
and they missed how is he the worst shot
ever
maybe they're trying to scare the dog so
he runs home so they're trying to follow
him what Corral them like a sheep I
don't know because shooting at him
doesn't seem like a good approach
up
what's your plan here man you're gonna
blow up the people oh what what how do
you
think
oh my God what's happened
[Music]
oh God
they're human beings
just shot a guy after blowing up here
we're after slipping a grenade Where Are
You Gonna escape to after shooting a guy
that's fair that's I mean
I want to see the blood of the snow
Georgia
yeah what's going on there
he looks like Rupert Grint but it does
like night at the cabinet like modern
Rupert Grint whoa that guy's cool
looking look at those eyebrows brows
it's beautiful work anti-eugine Levy
oh that explode it exploded yeah yeah
[Music]
gasoline
and grenades dude there were grenades in
there if you guessed the name of the dog
correctly I'll give you a hundred
dollars uh
uh
Mosby that's your one it's not great
obscure is the move don't feel proud of
that I Sparky
it's gonna be one of those movies isn't
it four stitches barely grazed it
what were they doing Flying that low
shooting in a dog at us yeah good
question it's fair Cabin Fever who knows
U.S number 31 calling mcmurdle come in
over
podcasters
first we got
smash
look to anybody on this entire continent
and you want me to reach somebody yes
good recap that's kind of the point of
the radio in general I think it's your
job probably maybe we had whirlwind
oh okay
Greg mentioned Tarantino I get it now I
can't condone it much myself but it is a
short haul
now or there an hour back [__] doc I'll
give you the lift nope nope I won't
forget it Palmer hey thanks for thinking
about it though
[Laughter]
it's quite the sausage fest it is a lot
of dudes the thing is like that's what
it's about ten things very subtle this
is really 10 Things I Hate About You
start beefing with each other I can't
get over how good his beard is yeah it's
like an immaculately thick beard it's
really good you don't want to fly we
don't fly you really want to save those
crazy sweets Norwegians Which Way doc
Southwest
gonna have through the map because I'm
going to be busy kind of crazy how they
shot this I mean unbelievable looking
just all the white out and lighting it
must have sucked Lighting in snow and
reflection of it all yeah
this man is in Sons of Anarchy
the prequel before
I also miss movies being lit so you can
actually see everything yeah like it's a
bright movie but it's still tense okay
there goes the UFO oh look at the UFO
it's crazy I can't identify it at all no
one can tell what it is what are you
flying object no will you turn that crap
down I'm trying to get some sleep I was
shocked today
[Music]
this must be this song is the 70s right
yeah I love when movies do that and
don't pretend like they're decades the
only decade that it drives me yeah
because I don't listen to Jess today
because today's music sucks
[Music]
I talk superstitious you can tell those
lyrics are poignant here though I'm
telling you that's the whole point if
you believe in things that you don't
understand you suffer
okay Shadow what you got oh I think
something's off of that dog not Swedish
imagine all week
Theory we assume the dog is good because
dogs are great no we don't you clearly
the dog's not good that's what I'm
saying is that we're gonna find them all
dead because the dog killed because like
we as an audience are like why are you
shooting at the dog but instead it's
it's playing an expectation yeah the
thing is inside the dog yeah and it's
already gotten these Folk
[Music]
the dog through the ax 100 yeah The
Shining
[Music]
everything was just so bright and now
it's such a gorgeous set yeah
[Music]
froze bled some too you say blood soap
true
Frozen blood icicle let's go that is
metal is fudge
oh like instantaneously Frozen
[Music]
the hell happened here come on Doc
he could have been Han Solo oh it'd been
great would have been great I mean I
love Harrison Harrison Ford's perfect
I'm just like in this era looking at him
it's like damn it would have been
different but totally A vibe or Indie
honestly they've got kind of similar
it's that like stoic badass thing yeah
like you want to know more but he won't
tell you let me dig through your beard
for all of your secrets wherever you
keep your secrets bearded man
[Music]
it remains of some animal buried in the
ice and they chopped it out but where is
it look at this
was that a suitcase or kerosene it said
on the thing like different kind of
gasoline like a different fuel those
companies
[Music]
to bury them that's kind also frozen
ground that's gonna be a [__]
they brought them home
[Music]
even though Frozen still smells that bad
well it's steaming so I think it's like
thawing so all the smells would be
coming out
keep it outside man Blair I'd like you
to start an autopsy right away this
moment is your impression that this is
the thing right now I think the thing
killed that okay I think the thing is
the hunter not the body you think this
is a human body I think it was I think
it's like a mutilated remain of a couple
bodies
[Music]
oh two yeah see like it looks like a
like a cell dividing I'm wondering if
when this thaws out it is the thing and
that the monsters it's like we're gonna
see a monster is two-headed I don't know
I I think your theories
I don't trust him mine's all based on
not trusting me okay I don't trust Mosby
he seems sketchy no drugs no alcohol
oh man the makeup is good in this I am
repulse that's why he's in the open
credits
it's so bad stop squeezing it so much my
dude is so viscous it was a Jello
appears to be anyway a normal City
internal organs
art
of your mouth
[Music]
to be normal
so it was a dude there's an eyeball yeah
this is like splitting why you say dude
I mean it looks male that's what men
look like to you from Boston no wonder
you're into women that's true that's if
that's the competition I know it's sad I
fall on I keep thinking that they're in
like a submarine that's what it feels
like it's so isolated it feels like lost
you know yeah and I think the framing's
helping that like that sense of enclosed
spaces and it's getting tighter totally
there's a hole outside but it feels like
that and the outside does like have a
black and white vastness like you talked
about so I like when it's inside its
color and dense
with the others where it belongs what's
his name you just said this mutt I know
but somebody's got a name
I don't know if I trust him is he
sleeping things gonna wreck
[Music]
why do they have so many dogs out there
I don't think it's companionship is
there like a liquid yeah or something
are they sled dogs
Little Shop of Horrors that was graphic
oh
wait what it keeps on furling yeah now
it's got like The Faculty tentacles
[Music]
it feels like something's inside yeah
I think that's the thing totally but can
he transform back and forth or oh or is
it just like
yeah I don't know oh
[Music]
oh that guy's dead I feel like it did
this it was in the other body as the
host and now it's moving back now it's
yeah
I mean that's fair
[Music]
wow he is just so interesting like he's
striking but let's look different it's
weird and pissed off whatever it is go
get child Mac wants the flamethrower Mac
wants to why that's what he said now
move
smart
I like that this movie just knows
skip the five steps goes right to the
flamethrower yeah
come on Charles
I think it's the first name we've heard
Mack wants the flamethrower
two names
oh it's like a dog shell
so that's practical what like what's
under that
oh it's like threading out to get into
the next thing oh it's spreading into
the other dogs I think
why is he stop why was he stopping him I
think he felt for the dogs but that dog
was dead
foreign
I would have let it burn a lot yeah I
would not have put that out yet
up
podcaster he's just got sunglasses at
night inside Antarctica
[Music]
it's like eating lobster oh that's why I
don't do it I don't mess with lobster
that's why I got a kick me out of Boston
no it's a Boston boy I wasn't welcome
anymore they told me to leave
they're like little cockroaches of the
ocean you like clam chowder
oh
Mexican food's better it's why I'm out
here do you love Mexican food and it
doesn't look like the thing when this
thing attacked our dogs it tried to
digest them absorb them the process
shape its own cells to imitate them
imitate them so it's not taking them
over it's trying to be we got to it
before it had time to finish finish what
finish imitating these dogs
so what does that mean that they got to
it before I had time to finish that he's
out there just not full-blown dog I'm
assuming there'll be some sort of
humanoid at some point
how long were you alone with that dog
I don't know an hour
and a half maybe
what the hell you looking at me like
what are you getting at it's nothing at
all
I think he's wondering how long it would
take what's that
looks like something buried under the
ice
a helicopter
UFO remember we did start in space here
is it the place where they're spending
most of their time pretty nasty out Mac
35 knots grew it I'm gonna go up anyway
not a nautical term yeah
Memorial
that hat is majestic
this has to be a UFO switch right it has
to be we met one at the top oh that's
cool it's a painting they just
stood in front of I feel like one of you
should stay up there at least okay
yeah it felt like all three of them were
about to go down let's go see what
happens yeah
how long you figure this has been in the
ice I'd say the Isis buried in is 100
000 years old at least so it's thawing
out the aliens a hundred thousand okay
we are
going back
was that where they're buried dude maybe
that's where they they got out thousands
of years ago it crashes and this thing
gets thrown out or crawls out and it
ends up freezing in the ice I just
cannot believe any of this Voodoo
[__] he's so young uh he's got a
great voice he works all the time now
[Music]
well this is I guess in this
assimilation if they are correct about
it well assembly likes to take over
right so like it's saying that it has
assimilated I thought this was the
assimilation of what they think is
happening no
I think no that's Refrigeration yeah
remember in the find of the century
that's going to win somebody the Nobel
Prize okay I don't trust it because when
they rushed out to meet the helicopter
it felt like there was like 20 of them
but now I don't know like
you uh got the keys I didn't trust it
there's something wrong with Blair he's
locked himself in his room and he won't
answer the door he needs to be alone and
in close proximity with the life form to
be absorbed so is Blair cracking up or
what in Blair that was cool get some
sleep
kind of rooting for this guy to die I
mean I don't like him
[Music]
you run right at minimum
at minimum
that's all he had to say
he did run I thought he ran towards the
guy and I was like bro
what are they doing out here in the
first place I think they're scientists
but they have army vehicles that's a
good point
that's my way to get there
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah he's gonna light him on fire got to
they've shown that works yeah yep
[Music]
foreign
for 10 years he's my friend
you gotta burn the rest of them
is it only 10 but like I don't know I
wish we knew this movie does not care if
you like its characters know its
characters it's really about the yeah
like the horror of it that's kind of
cool even know what they're sciencing
[Music]
oh
so they have to burn the rest of them
because if if the organism stays any
cells yeah it seems like they can divide
yeah
they gotta go find the original guy that
was with the dog who locked himself in
the room that they questioned yes
oh and the chef
I can't find Blair okay if I Blair okay
Blair Windows is in the radio room still
trying to get through everyone else in
the rec room
you go on I'll be in in a minute don't
do that don't trust it here we go find
Blair because Blair's obviously been
infected yeah Blair's gonna be our first
human one I think like fully formed it
can be in multiple places at multiple
times that's why I think it's a spring
yeah yeah nobody gets in and out of here
nobody
podcaster got messed up go around to the
bathroom door talk to him
so he's going crazy because he's been
slightly infected by this thing I assume
he's not an imitation because I don't
think I could replicate this level but
maybe
like why is he doing this because he's
going crazy I'm guessing
come on man you don't want to hurt
anybody
[Music]
does he know podcasters in the room I
don't think so I think he would have
killed him yeah oh cool really cool good
use of tables yeah that's why you asked
for the table
to Ram them
damn
great Foley work yeah I was just
thinking
I want him in my shack we'll lock him in
the tool ship
are they carrying the doctor or I think
I think the Dr Blair
yeah
what kind of drugs just stupefy you what
happened I think they're gonna like
exorcism it out like is he crazy or
possessed might have nothing to do with
the guy remember at the beginning they
were like you can go crazy down here
which I imagine happens a lot so
probably that it was just paired wide
hey what why don't you just trust in the
Lord
works out great see how that goes for
you watch Clark
and watch him close did you hear me
watch him the dog guy is his name Clark
because he was around for around half
Clark so when he locked himself with her
I think so I thought he had locked
himself in a room everyone that's seen
this movie is judging us so hard I know
because they're like they should know
this here's the truth it doesn't matter
this movie is awesome oh it's riveting
there's no plot like it's not a full
plot movie and you don't know the
characters it's an experience movie yeah
how do we know who's human if I was an
imitation how would you know if it was
really me I'll break Agatha Christie
yeah
love this possibly have been thinking
about a blood serum test you could take
a sample of each person's blood but mix
it with uncontaminated blood as if
there's a reaction we'd know who isn't
human classic we've got whole blood and
storage let me start working on it keep
an eye on Clark
he's close to that dog yeah that must be
Clark we've got like half the names now
you think Clark's a red herring
I think so it knows what this organ is
but get the rest of his notebooks start
going through but is he far gone because
of the space Madness or like alien man I
think it's the spaceman because like I'd
go crazy there and then the stimuli the
alien Lake
gushy
oh [__]
bro
what
where's clock right here
wait a minute wait a minute was this
broken into the lockers on I feel like
the doctor's the one then 100 who's got
access to it
yep who else could I use that key I just
give it a cover whenever he needs it
could anybody have gotten it from Utah I
don't see how as soon as I'm finished I
return it right away it's got a nose
ring I told you the nose ring guy just
missed it the only one who's got any
business with it oh now wait a minute
Gary you've been in here on several
occasions
yeah me too I would be too yeah put it
down Gary you don't want to hurt anybody
on the floor
now I don't want him to die yeah
suddenly endearing because I'm him he
took off the glasses yeah now he's not
such a d
you can shoot them
is he
I love this because you don't know
all right
place your bets red herring dog guy
Giles is fine
one of the other three could it be Kurt
he's too big a movie star
[Music]
like he's destroying all the evidence to
like seem like he got it there's so many
they're growing
this thing doesn't want to show itself
he wants to hide inside an imitation it
takes us over
and it has no more enemies nobody left
to kill it and then it's one this is
awesome so glad I knew nothing about
this yeah me too there's a storm hitting
Us in six hours we're gonna find out
who's who
let me let me know what you're gonna
break the needle in mind he's doing a
real fun job okay they're gonna do that
one other thing rips through your
clothes when it takes you over Windows
found some shredded long johns but the
name tag was missing
nobody trusts anybody now make everybody
take their pants off that's the trick
issue classline hit hard you should go
back into the other room everybody get
naked right now let me see your name
tags drop trial who cut holes in their
pants
RJ McCready helicopter pilot U.S Outpost
North 31. helicopter pilot U.S Outpost
is it like a protection like a defense
for America like Antarctica what are we
protecting from I don't understand your
job sir
and everyone should prepare their own
meals and I suggest we only eat out of
cans you're really weird if you were it
and suggested that but I wouldn't
surprise me this has been very like good
at twisties any of them move you fry
them you hear anything anything at all
you cut loose on the sirens we all meet
back here in 20 minutes regardless real
close
they roped up dog guy definitely a red
herring though I feel like he's good
[Laughter]
how many of them do you think are not
okay it's like two or three yeah at this
point
wouldn't it be crazy if they're all fine
they killed them all in the First Act
they're not gonna address it
won't harm anybody you've got to let me
come back inside you saw what I saw
right yeah there was a news between the
two of them and it was hanging tangling
like what
foreign
he might be
yeah his innocent face I don't trust it
and they first offered him to be the guy
oh the leader yeah it was stash in his
own oil furnace when must this lasted
but I don't think he saw me fighting I
cut him moose he's one of them what do
you think he got to him I don't know so
that's Mac yeah which is Russell so he
must be because he yeah like he got his
clothes on yeah
hello do you think he's changed
hit a guideline cut it loose
anyone messes with me and the whole
campus
put those torches on the floor and back
off badass move yeah ba move
smooth
bomb move
free this what happened
[Applause]
oh
clear oh
[Music]
okay I guess correctly that he had it
inside him uh oh God
[Music]
unbelievable looking
incredible work
oh
that's so cool
[Laughter]
do they not see the head I don't think
this I think it's under a chair or
something
those are like things coming out of his
come on yeah yeah I mean that's
tradition for alien things
Roger does
Roger's on it
all right you're getting a little
flamethrower happy I do worry there's an
entire building you're in
everybody's down real tight what for for
your health
[Music]
you would also he just blew up the other
guy why would it be him that's close
enough Clark he ain't tying me up
then I'll have to kill you child
then kill me
he does look familiar to me he's in
Requiem for a Dream yeah bad guy I think
I've seen it he's a lot of stuff he's
really really talented I guess you do oh
I don't think he had the thing nope just
just dude we're gonna find out who's the
thing
wash the knife bro
not watching it denim's very sanitary
like if you the organism might oh
podcaster's name is Windows
you should have switched to Mac should
have would have gone better for you Mac
and windows sooth saying this new before
wow
I'm back and I'm a PC one's cool one's
nerdy it's all right there oh yeah you
also didn't see him stab him like he
could have maybe I don't know
it's a clever test though
I'll show you what I already know
[Laughter]
oh yeah
now Clark
Clark
oh they're on his dad right yeah I think
on the right yeah
and clock was human huh
which makes you a murderer don't it
I mean he swung Adam his instincts don't
agree oh Palmer you were the only one
that could have got to that blood
cool
oh
why is Windows just hanging out
oh no
[Music]
oh
Palmer was really Incognito for a minute
that's what happened yep oh
what's up with your flamethrower very
unreliable
[Music]
I don't know that you can get more fire
it's pretty on fire
[Music]
what a stunt it's gonna be real cold
inside now yep
now the organisms are everywhere let's
breathe it in just keep breathing
[Music]
he got eight
go to the board games what are we gonna
do we know that oh okay so we still
tests
no it's Niles nulls
nulls
learning the names like third out what
are Childs it is child's wait now it's
not Niles and Childs are those Childs
I thought it was like Giles
I don't remember what I thought it was
originally now
how would they play this on TV I
remember like this was on like TNT when
we were kids like what how what do you
show we're going out to give Blair the
test if he tries to make it back here
and we're not with him I don't know who
the him left
so it's child's now now Mack and the
eyebrows yeah okay I don't know if we've
gotten eyebrows his name yet no he just
did oh what was it I don't know it was
in the petri dish but his hand was over
it
[Music]
oh that sounds okay
and he's out he escaped but also he's
his shoulders have noose
he's in there
I nope I wouldn't not nope why is there
like
how many days did you guys leave him
it's a spaceship player's been busy out
here all by himself how long was he out
there what
you stole the parts from the helicopter
smart SOB put it together piece by piece
where was he trying to go space any
place but here okay that's the first
part of the movie that actually doesn't
make full sense because like somebody
explained that if that was like two days
and they wouldn't have just put him so
maybe he'd been working on for a lot
longer that's what he does but then they
accidentally put him in that building
above it yeah maybe
foreign
[Music]
ADR moment
cut to their faces we need this plot
point
they did a focus group did you guys
understand that they were not going to
get out of their life throw it in we
should say it directly
someone should have explained the ship
to us
how did he build it we need lots yeah
that part that's the only thing so
completely flabbergasted yeah
[Music]
it's a caterpillar in there so they're
trying to heat things up so that this
thing can't freeze wherever it is they
don't know where it is
practice
do you think that there is a rescue team
that's going to come and somebody's
going to get out alive I I'm thinking
it's gonna be pretty nihilistic and they
all die yeah but also the alien could
just wander into the cold and and
hibernate right
I was thinking that like
why it's not stuck there maybe he's
lonely he just wants to be home with his
friends generator room
because I think we
10 or 15 minutes left in this
see I can't tell if it's like a
denouement or if the third act's gonna
end like yeah
some of this is so built out like
we also never really get in a sense of
setting yeah which works for the mystery
I've just realized we haven't been
anywhere like this yet yeah
so cold to film yeah like they look
freezing
gone gone crazy
yeah how do you fix that we got to bring
this whole place right down into the ice
Gary Planters in the old storage room
all down by the generator no
no
do you think you'd be nice to know
that was no not now just no no no
oh
so now they all trust each other but
they can't trust a third of them now and
he knows to do that Roger
whatever his name Gary you know Roger
Gary nulls no it's not now Todd no Todd
was at the beginning the name that we
read
a real person
so the guy who was shooting the doctor
he was crazy the whole time he was
infected the whole time yeah and he was
building a thing so I'm wondering if
like he was infected before the movie
started to me that's what makes it why
he was able to build it that whole time
because he's an alien creature you know
the dog brought it didn't it or was it
already there because if the dog brother
is still only like a week
yeah but he alien moved fast you saw
flash that's true that's your quick
aliens
that thing with the face with the holes
was
um the whole thing yeah and they dragged
him away by his own face like putting
your fingers in somebody's so cool okay
maybe he doesn't want to leave yet thing
because he wants them all to die first
oh maybe
oh we're going full like lovecraftian
well there that goes
please
[Music]
time to do a somersault
gotta look cool
[Music]
it looks so non-cg so real it's just so
beautiful it's so nice to see an
explosion it was like that was like we
built this thing yeah yeah yeah
like they blew up a chunk of Antarctica
for us yeah yeah where do you think they
shot this maybe they're they look cold
there's space I feel like maybe Alaska
Alaska
ever so off to get a little accent
oh
how did he survive that I don't know but
when he started walking away I knew that
the movie was going to make him survive
it because he had a great last line
that's why that's why he's got the
temperature up all over the camp it
won't last long though yeah we've got
any surprises for each other I don't
think we're in much shape to do anything
about it
what do we do play here for a little
while see what happens uh it seems like
a non-plan like dying
yeah cool I was kind of hoping they
would do that I like that a lot I like
the the nihilistic ending
okay let's get everybody's name okay
McCready uh-huh that was Wilford Brimley
as Blair a name that we missed complete
okay nulls TK Carter Palmer I think we
said one maybe I don't know which one
though Keith David's name child's
child's
sorry Norris we might have said in the
beginning I don't think
don't think I said bendings
Clark
Gary I know I threw a Gary in there at
least once Gary was said Fuchs
the other Tom Waits wait which one was
podcast he was winning Wednesday yeah
yeah not a PC Norwegian yeah wow there's
very few actors oh yeah it's just the
people yeah like lives like a bottle
movie almost because it was like one set
which is cool which is why I think they
blew it up oh stun people y'all 10 of
them thanks guys that's great that's
incredible like this is most the credits
that's in like that's it yeah what it
takes to make a movie based on a story
who goes there did you know that no I
wonder if it's like an alien paranoid
Thriller and they just moved it up I
like who goes there as a title but the
thing is just got so much power to it
pop it's lasted what 40 years like the
thing is still one of those classic
titles and the font and everything
I had this moment a few times in the
movie where I kept thinking like this
feels like a classic movie like when
you're watching it and you're like oh
this is important it was so simple yeah
um and just like unbelievably executed
like you know when you re-watch movies
from your childhood like predator or
alien or any of the movies that we
actually did see yeah and they feel like
nostalgic yeah this felt nostalgic the
first time
like there was elements I know what you
mean where you're just like oh like that
makes sense that this says with the test
of time yeah it's just it whole it holds
up I guess there's like a built-in
importance because it's like so
meticulous but also freeing it was not
until we got to the like whodunit aspect
of it not even who or who is it yeah
that I was like I see what why this is
the thing yeah the First Act I was like
oh it's a cool Creature Feature totally
and and the because of the costume
because of the design because of all
that I was like oh okay this is a this
is a classic yeah but then when we got
to the actual premise when we got to
like what where what we're supposed to
be guessing feeling yeah then I was like
oh that's why this this that's why this
is still watched still talked about and
I'd seen some of the design like some of
those gifts are iconic like the things
exploding and the guy's head coming off
the shoulder like that but I still never
knew anything which is cool like we got
to watch this fresh 40 years later it it
didn't feel like it is a horror movie
but it didn't feel so scary it because
it felt real it felt like oh this is how
I would be feeling if I was there no one
did stupid stuff yeah like no one ran
upstairs so there's a couple of times
where we were like don't do that don't
go down there yeah but overall still I'm
a little unclear on how he built that
spaceship no idea I have I'm gonna ask
everyone immediately after this it's
fine though that's fine it was still I
mean it allowed a ticking Time Bomb like
you need that incident in the third act
yeah but it definitely felt like we
needed it not that it made sense yeah
definitely how do you feel about the
fact that we don't know any of the
characters
I think I would be bothered by it if it
wasn't for the level of suspense we
still felt yeah like you and I were
still riveted without the names totally
and usually you're not watching
something having to repeat the name you
just don't know and then you see and
you're like oh that's who where he was
you know I prefer this to those scenes
where it's like hello Tom how are you
today yeah and you're like wow yeah
there was very little Exposition in this
honestly and there is very little like I
knew no one yeah they didn't care if you
did and I think that is a unique sense
of tension because you have to like them
or not immediately and like then like
Windows grow on us and stuff yeah
podcast boy podcast yeah Windows was uh
interesting and then the other part that
the other guy that was interesting was
the guy that dies right before Windows
where we shot him right and and they'll
find out he's human and we both thought
it was a red herring but I like that
they kept manipulating that by having
him tied up and we were like okay are
they doubling down yeah yeah completely
and I really liked Childs the whole time
but I liked that we were supposed to to
be suspicious but I couldn't tell if
that's because I know the actors work I
don't think it's a surprise that Childs
and Mac are the two at the end too
because child's the only one who even
though he didn't know his name he's the
only one who we knew right and he seemed
capable the whole time yeah which I like
that everyone that like survived were
the ones that you could hope in the
beginning would is your interpretation
at the end that the one of the two of
them has the thing in them my
interpretation is that they die and the
thing still survives because like it
could just go out in the cold but like
if he so it
in either of them then the things still
ready well the thing was you know the
dog and all the things were represented
so it could be that was the everything
like all of it that was left but I don't
feel like that would be enough with the
things we got shown I think that the
thing the thing needs a host to live
sure and without hosts then so there's
only two hosts left right I'm assuming
that that the doc we said the big thing
that happened at the end was the doc
mixed with the guy everything left yeah
so that's dead because we
um through a dynamite at it right so I'm
assuming that either the thing is dead
or it's in child's or Mac so using one
of them well I think that the problem is
Max says why don't we just sit here and
wait it out which is what somebody who
has the host in them would say because
you want to and Charles is so tired he
didn't do anything to test anything
right but if you so if you don't have it
in you
not to be but you should off yourself
right you know if as an audience member
we're watching going I trust Kurt
Russell because we just saw him take out
the other thing right but from a
dialogue and an ending standpoint you
know you're gonna die either way right
so if I didn't have it in me in that
moment I would burn the other person
right and then eliminate all options and
yeah like get rid of variables but they
don't and they're both there right and
we know they can't both be the thing or
they would know that they were both the
thing and then they would just be fine I
do kind of feel like one of them is the
thing do you think it like left like a
piece of it was able to get into him no
maybe I think child if anyone because he
just stumbles up like hey I was just
looking for Blair yeah and that seemed
like a line yeah I'm with you I'm with
you but if it isn't child then Kurt in
15 minutes you're gonna have to snap
into it Mac and you're gonna have to see
I think Mac was just out like he was
just done like I don't think he had
anything left to fight like I don't
think he had any he said that but no I
think he's gonna wake up he's like you
think the thing too is like this very
clearly set up so that there could be a
sure and that was a big thing in the 80s
yeah I mean there's serialized content
now but there's not a lot of sequels now
you know what I mean like this felt like
it could have a sequel not like a
franchise this is a uh I guess
I don't know this for a fact I assume
there is no thing too I don't think I've
heard of a thing too or if it wasn't
well loved because this is beloved and
I've heard the thing too yeah do you
feel like they could do that today
well so at one of the major strengths of
this is the Prosthetics and the
Practical yeah but that was one of the
only flaws I had was at the end when you
see the full size of it there was a
moment I would have liked another 10
seconds before he blew it up so I felt
the sense of dread intention because I
felt like you're like it was like big
reveal and all of a sudden it was like
awesome line of dialogue like 80s and
then it then it was over so there was
all this escalation and then the actual
climax moment was so short so I think
that was because they could only show it
so much because you'll notice once it
was fully formed they like hit a lot of
it for budgetary purpose yeah and just
for like design because you'd want it
like the fear of the thing is how
amorphous and alien it is so if you show
too much it's less scary so I do feel
like the only weakness in that last beat
was that it was like all this building
building and it explodes whereas I would
have I think modern audiences there'd be
a bit more of that like build to the oh
no he's not gonna make it but I don't
want to see this with CGI like this was
this would not work with a CGI villain
and do you think that today doing this
with practicals would just make it too
expensive to even make money I don't
think studios are willing to risk what
this would take today because otherwise
a lot a lot of movies be better because
half the time you see bad C drives like
well they should have taken a chance and
done practical and they just don't like
I really worry about the fact that we're
cutting corners on the movies that make
a billion dollars so why would a movie
that maybe make my like 500 million
dollars yeah because if the big studios
are cutting corners on CGI there's no
way they're going to invest in the human
element if they did do a thing today I
feel like they would have to almost like
I I don't feel like Kurt Russell is in
it and is like hears that there's
something goes like I feel like we still
don't know what happened and then you
just put the other pieces one of them
got out and I think the only way to do
it today is to do the second act and
later creature and do it a tiny budget
film and make the first act all suspense
and who done it you know what I can't
stand about myself that like the first
thing I'm thinking about when this ends
because of the ambiguity of it is like a
sequel yeah and it's like wait that
movie was bomb it was full circle like
it was enough but then my 2023 brain is
like but what see my thought is that the
ending being ambiguous is good because
it doesn't have a sequel so I have the
same thought like what if there's a
sequel glad there's not I think yeah no
I'm glad there's not two but I will but
I wish there were I'm glad there's not
but see I I'm getting a little
franchised out yeah completely you're
that's absolutely right like when
cocaine buried and I was like that was a
cocaine bear and like I felt good about
like all right that's a whole last movie
whereas like I'm very worried about the
fact that I I like your thought I was
like what sounds different do you not
like cocaine bear isn't that supposed to
be made for me and I was just like it's
a movie about a bear on cocaine no it
wasn't bad and I loved that about it it
wasn't the thing though I mean it's not
gonna be like we're not gonna talk about
cool camera for 40 years so what do you
think in terms of did this hold like
people talking about this oh this was
definitely the movie that I was promised
okay you yeah I almost feel like I
thought I wasn't gonna like it as much
uh another I haven't seen what is it the
fly is that the other thing we'll talk
about Jeff Goldblum yeah he's the fly um
I think and I I don't know in my head I
think I like confused the tooth the
thing of the fly I'm one of these
article noun movies I don't know
Cronenberg but there's article nouns I
haven't seen a lot of these types of
movies so I kind of they all blur
together a little bit not not that the
Flies this type of movie just like I
love this it's like a creature review
something like that yeah I haven't seen
a lot of movies from the 80s and I
haven't seen a lot of horror movies from
the 80s so all I knew didn't know that
this had anything to do with aliens I
didn't know that it was gonna be Kurt
Russell I didn't know that it was going
to be Antarctica like a desolate like I
did didn't know anything about this so I
just had heard that a lot of my horror
friends loved it so I thought it would
be really scary yeah and very nostalgic
so I was really pleasantly surprised
that I think that this is just like a
true great movie beginning middle end
that didn't do the things that usually I
care about which is like backstory and
character it just or plot development
like it didn't do any of that and I
still loved it which is interesting it
to me was the thing that I think a lot
of Studios try to espouse which is like
turn your brain off and enjoy it and it
wasn't turned to burn off because it's
dumb it was we don't need all that stuff
you just described but successfully like
some people say theme park ride about
like Transformers and stuff and that
doesn't feel good whereas this is a
theme park ride that felt good like it
was fulfilling as a ride the experience
was fulfilling yeah I really I really F
with that movie yeah I thought this was
spectacular that was really good I also
think that it was nostalgic in that I
recognized some of the influences but it
didn't feel like I was worried about
where like when I watched The Godfather
I'd already seen Men in Tights 100 times
so I felt like I'd already seen like the
comedy version so by the time I watched
The Godfather I was like
I liked it but I didn't feel that like
profound sense of like Cinema I was like
oh that was a movie whereas this I could
see how it influenced things but I
didn't feel like I'd already seen it
yeah wow this is really good yeah dug
this and also I could see why Cronenberg
influenced a lot of filmmakers I can see
like the cronenbergian uh use of special
effects which is referenced I know uh
Fantastic Four a lot of people tried to
make a Cronenberg body horror thing
multiple times didn't work but like I
definitely feel the impact of this movie
without and also the gifts and things
I've seen like memes of it but it didn't
ruin the experience I knew Kurt Russell
was in it only because of memes but it
didn't make me it didn't change anything
yeah and also just not with horror but
with mystery also yeah it's definitely
yeah I think we're in the middle of it
you're like Knives Out moment yeah
Agatha Christie yeah all of a sudden I
was like they're they're going to have
that thing where they're trying to
figure out who's the the bad one on the
playing trainer automobile yeah and you
can see at the second that we start
questioning in the car like wait he's
been there what's happening here and you
start thinking oh my God some of them
have it and I love that this is probably
going to be fun for people to watch
because we hadn't seen it and they have
like a lot of people probably grew up
watching this and they would be like
what what a silly thing for adults to
not know and so that's gonna be joyous
to see them think we know what's going
on we never did did you in the last two
hours come up with the name of somebody
from Boston that is uh a woman
um I can't say it did you
uh that's how I was in the movie I was I
was so enthralled in the film it at one
point halfway through I was like oh
Sarah Silverman and then I was like oh
no no it's because she's a Jew not
because she's from Boston
you're like okay let me process women in
filmmaking wait wrong category what have
I done uh yeah so we don't know if
that's gonna stay in the cut but uh at
one point uh Roxy and I were just trying
to name people from Boston only dudes
came to mind but there are women in
Boston there are and they the many
talented successful ones that's one of
them I uh well you're out here you know
what you're the first woman from Boston
yeah you did it JoJo went to
Northeastern I don't know he's from
Boston though that's the thing it's so
tricky we're gonna we're gonna solve
this mystery that's the thing uh people
in the comments leave your favorite
woman from Boston let us know who you
enjoy from that world has nothing to do
with the thing but we're curious uh this
was awesome I had so much fun this
actually lived up to very lofty
expectations if there are any other
Cronenberg films 80s films Thrillers
anything you think we might not have
seen because that's a definitely a void
in my film knowledge blind spot for me
like I don't have it maybe the fly I'd
love to watch the fly if you enjoyed
this uh like share subscribe that way we
know that you did that'll inform us to
maybe watch The Fly let us know in the
comments what you want us to check out
next thank you for being a reject we
appreciate you all very much we will see
you next time for more or koi and Roxy
don't watch movies from before they were
born but should here in real Rejects
foreign